hey good morning everybody whoo I got a
little raspy there I've been doing a lot
of time lately yesterday
I interviewed Senator Marco Rubio I
interviewed congressman Dan Crenshaw and
I interviewed Michael in del the my
pillow guy it was a crazy crazy day of
interviews and then I in between I'm
also doing a lot of press now for don't
burn this book which doesn't come out
till April 28th but were stacking
interviews so that a ton of stuff can
come out that week so I was talking I
mean none stopped talking from like 8
a.m. to about 9 p.m. and then we had a
bunch of meetings with our staff and the
rest of it and actually the only time
that I really didn't talk throughout the
day was during the interview with
Michael and Dell who this guy you know
the my pillow guy and what happened to
him a couple weeks ago what about two
weeks ago now he was at the Rose Garden
with Trump and he had converted his my
pillow Studios estudios his my pillow
factories to make masks they're making
about 50,000 s a day and then the media
just tried to absolutely attack him and
it's like these people who do no good
for anyone attack this guy they were
also attacking him because he talked
about God and Jesus oh my oh no oh Lord
while he's doing this great work so we
had a really fascinating talk but he's
one of these people that he's so
energetic he's so into what he's doing
he's so like obviously living the life
he's supposed to live but he just talks
and talks and talks and talks and talks
and talks and I love the interview but I
basically just had to sit here and not
fall out of my chair anyway guys we are
doing the direct messages every Monday
and Wednesday 8:45 a.m. Pacific 11:45
a.m. Eastern I have not eaten yet I just
have my coffee here and quick clerical
stuff right up top just a reminder
everybody if you're watching this thing
on YouTube which is the only place it's
on click that little bell so that you
might just might get subscribe to our
videos then you might just actually see
them in our feet it's still uh it's
still a coin toss with the YouTube
gremlins but give it a shot if you can
and when I take questions here which
I'll do in a little bit oh I'm only
taking questions from subscribers at
Rubin report com so we're you know the
YouTube chats not on I'm not doing it
off Twitter or anywhere else and if you
join us at Rubin report com
you get our full videos 5 days early so
our interview this week with Dana Perino
which is just in clips on YouTube right
now and will be full on YouTube on
Sunday is already up at Rubin report
calm and it's ad free of course we've
got ad free podcasts and all that good
stuff and of course you can pre-order
don't burn this book the actual copies
have arrived as many of you have seen
and I've been signing and personalizing
a bunch of copies to to some of the
people that have influenced me most and
whose ideas I try to expand upon and
further in this book so I'm getting
those out soon and we're gonna be doing
a big book signing the day that it comes
out and a live stream and all that good
stuff some interesting little press
notes finally after about literally
20-some odd years of trying I will be on
Real Time with Bill Maher on May 29th so
that's exciting I don't know that we'll
be in studio he's doing it from his
backyard but we live in strange times
and there's a lot going on so what I
wanted to talk to you about today though
was something that I sort of I would say
I pepper through a lot of the things
that I do here which is about the amount
of time that we spend online and one of
the things we do in the Rubin Report
community we've been doing these Sunday
afternoon movies so at 1 p.m. Pacific
each week we've been doing a movie I
didn't do it this past week because I
did do a weekend off which is something
that I actually really recommend
although since quarantine and lockdown
and everything else is started it's like
our only way of really communicating is
being online so I've been doing it more
on the weekends but two weeks ago we
watch The Matrix and we did the Netflix
party thing so we could all chat
throughout the movie it was it was
totally fun and you know matrix is just
a brilliant brilliant classic you know
it's it's the red pill movie right but
underneath the matrix and the cool
effects and everything else and the
fighting and all that stuff is the basic
idea that there is a digital world out
there now this movies from I think about
20 years ago already but the idea is
that there's this digital world out
there and we the organic things that we
are as humans that the more we sort of
give over to that world the more
time we spend in that world that
ultimately we just become batteries for
that digital world so if you haven't
seen the movie you got to see it and I'm
not really blowing anything here but you
can all sort of picture for those of you
that have seen and if you haven't seen
it it's not really much of a spoiler
because movies been out for twenty years
I think I got a twenty year window on a
spoiler thing but that that you know
there's that scene where you see the
humans just they're basically the
batteries that keep the digital
electronic world alive and you know
we're in a really weird spot right now
because for the last 20 years we've all
been spending more and more time online
more and more social networks have come
and gone and and you know we've handed
over more information to them and we
watch more video online and now because
of the way we are with social distancing
and being in lockdown it's like all of
our communication right now is this
right like this is you you're probably
sitting at a laptop possibly in bed
maybe you haven't even got up yet or
you're watching on you know Apple TV or
at your computer or whatever it is but
all of our communication the way we're
now talking to our friends and family I
mean think about it for the last month
if you've talked basically to anyone in
your family unless they live in your
house you know we're doing it through
zoom and we're doing it through FaceTime
and you know we're tweeting all the time
and facebooking and all that stuff and
see this is one of the interesting
things it's like I don't want to be one
of those people that just look at it
like oh this is some evil thing I mean
it's it's incredible actually the way
it's it's connected us and it's freed us
in many ways and so many new voices are
out there and so many of the things that
I care about calling out mainstream
media lies all of that stuff it's like
it's because of this and also look at my
life I mean I'm in the garage of my
house and we've got a studio and we've
got a control room and a green room and
people often before this thing would
come here and chat and we get this out
on those pipes so I I love all of this
stuff but you know it's sort of like
fire right like it's it's a technology
it's a it's a tool and fire is really
great right you can cook food on it and
it can warm you in the winter and a
whole bunch of other stuff but it can
also burn you and it could burn your
house down and a whole bunch of other
things so I just think right now we have
to figure out ways to kind of balance
maybe a little bit better because I
sense this with everybody
kind of like you know the temperament of
average people right now that are just
spending more time online and suddenly
are seeing all the the fights and the
wars and the partisan stuff so my guys
gave me some interesting numbers here
that I thought you guys would would find
sort of enlightening so in North America
people right now spend an average of two
point four hours per day on social media
I mean that's actually 10% of your day
that you're spending online now if
you're also sleeping for let's say eight
hours a day that is a huge chunk of our
waking hours that we're spending staring
at these things and actually when I saw
that number it actually seemed kind of
low to me especially right now I mean
really think about it how much time
you're spending just sitting online
looking at things watching things
consuming things talking to people on
the rest of it now I get it because of
this unique times like how many things
can you do in your house like we started
a puzzle we have this giant Yoda Lego
thing that we've been meaning to get to
we take a lot of walks with the dog
we're cooking a ton but I get like the
whole thing has sort of pushed us and
and funneled us into this and it's not
just specifically online but the amount
of time we're watching television we
started The Sopranos again which David
had never seen and I had missed the
first two seasons we're in the middle of
season three right now and it's true
it's true art like it's truly cool so
again I'm not saying that watching all
these things is bad and binge watching
and all that but but it's a lot of us
just sort of passively doing things
related to the television by the way
during quarantine overall TV viewership
has risen by over 17 percent which is a
tremendous amount 39% for children 2 to
11 and 46 percent for kids 12 to 17 I
mean that seems dangerous now now I'm
not a parent yet so I don't want to pass
judgment on anyone that is now you know
locked in their house with their young
kids and I get it my brother and sister
have young kids and it's tough right
like now you've got you have to work
both both my brother and sister work and
their spouses have full-time jobs right
and now suddenly you've got the kids in
the house all day long and sometimes
it's easier to just hand them an iPad or
turn on the TV or whatever it is I'm not
talking about siblings specifically like
I get
but these numbers like this will just
sort of a dict future generation a young
generation more thirty nine percent up
to two eleven and forty six twelve to
seventeen and by the way when i said
that two point four hours on social
media that we're spending right now
that's that's an hour increase since the
start of partying which again that seems
kind of low to me i suspect we're all
spending a lot more time and i'd love to
hear your feedback on this and and how
you guys are managing it you know some
of the little little tips and tricks
that i offer at the end of don't burn
this book which you can get it don't
burn this book calm in Chapter ten I
sort of lay out what I think are some of
the ideas that I think can can make us a
little more functional a little more
whole a little more a little more happy
through the madness and obviously I
wrote this before quarantine but a lot
of a lot of what I talk about is how to
do a little bit of a digital detox so
most of you know I do for the last three
years I've done it and I'll do it again
this year I've done August off-the-grid
no phone no TV no news no nothing and it
gets increasingly difficult because
stuff is everywhere one of the beauty
beauties that I have is because now
people know me they keep me honest so
like I'd be at the supermarket in the
middle of August and I'm like yeah my
backwards hat on and a tank top and
shorts and I'm like disconnected beyond
belief and someone will come up to me
and be like hey Gabe you're you're
really offline come on man let me let me
see let me see your pockets you know see
if I have a phone in there and I'd
literally have to like empty my pockets
like no phone no phone the only thing
that I did sort of stay connected
through was the GPS in my car I have a
terrible sense of direction and I felt
that that was pretty much okay also I
don't know how to even disable the
freaking screen in front of you so but
but there are a few little tips and
tricks that I offer here that I guess I
could tease out for you guys right now I
think one of one of the things and and
I'm pretty good at we we don't always do
it but we've become pretty good at it is
don't bring your phone into your bedroom
especially right now where your office
now suddenly may be your bedroom your
office may be your kitchen we're we
don't have functional hours anymore you
know like I think one of the things that
will be lost in all this there's there's
some good stuff about the way we're
while figuring out how to work right now
like the fact that many many people are
not commuting as long I live here in LA
with which has the most bananas traffic
in the world
maybe not the world but like we're
pretty high up there and you know before
I had the home studio like pretty much
anywhere you go in LA especially if it's
it's rush hour you're attacking on an
hour each way like even if you're trying
to get literally three months I look
pretty close to the highway here and
sometimes the mile to get to the exit is
it could take 45 minutes I mean I'm
actually not making that up it's it's
truly ridiculous so it's kind of cool
right now that you know a lot of you
guys now you don't have to do the
commute you don't have to sit in the car
you don't have to get on the train all
of that stuff I mentioned in the book
and I think I said this in one of the
livestreams the other day that my dad
who just retired at 71 years old he
worked we grew up in Long Island he
worked in New York City his whole life
so he worked over 40 years almost 90% of
that at one company actually and he
would take about a 50 to an hour minute
a 50 to 50 minutes to an hour train ride
every day on the Long Island Rail Road
to get to Penn Station to then take a
walk to the office and blah blah blah he
did that over 40 years that's basically
two hours a day forty years that was
over two hours of his life now my dad's
pretty highly functional so he would
read a lot and do things do work and all
that kind of stuff or sometimes I
suppose just nap but the idea that we're
able to rethink our lives right now
except now you've got that extra time
you've got other people in the house and
that we sort of never we don't have
normal hours so in a normal workday if
you worked in a normal office you know
the sort of average office maybe you
work from say 9:00 to 6:00 something
like that yet your lunch break and
whatever else but now it sort of never
ends so those of us that are that are in
the digital space more in the digital
world or more my my guys that work for
me it's like we all have crazy crazy
hours like we're texting each other at
nine o'clock and I try to be very
respectful of everybody and I really try
not to have my guys working on the
weekends and I'm also a firm believer
and I say this to them all the time it's
like as long as you do your work I don't
care when you do it you know you mean
you want to be up at 3:00 a.m.
sending a bajillion emails like as long
as I didn't miss anything during the day
because of that we're
good so I think that we're gonna really
be rethinking how we work where we work
when we work and it's really really cool
but I am I still beneath all that this
idea that we are now so dependent we
went from being super dependent on big
tech right super dependent that YouTube
is giving us the videos we want which we
know I mean guys I don't have to tell
you at this point it's like we we have
out on a 1.3 million subscribers on this
channel which they hid the subscriber
numbers basically now it used to be
something you could be proud of it's
sort of irrelevant to me at this point
but like we know that when I do a live
stream if that if that gets out to 2% of
you like that's a lot you know what I
mean like we just know and by the way
I'm not even calling that a conspiracy
with YouTube just whatever is going on
with the algorithm with all of these
things we've become so dependent in the
way we can get information and then
communicate with each other you guys
know this the Twitter Terms of Service
now has shadow banning in they are
telling us we can Debus we can hide
certain people and amplify other people
they're putting it in the Terms of
Service so it's like we went from you
know old the old days of 2019 to knowing
that big tech had this huge amount of
power over us and all the things that
Facebook's doing with your feet and your
data and all that stuff they this huge
amount of power and then now we've just
decided we're all going into that world
even more and I just think we have to be
wise about what we're doing there that's
one of the reasons by the way that I
created locals calm and what we've built
with Rubin report and Bridgette fantasy
is now on there and Michael malice is
now on there and zoo bees now on there
and and he know is on there and you're
on Brooke is on there and we're about to
add a couple other people some some
really big names soon it's not a giant
platform it's just allowing these
individual people to own their
communities own their data and you can
communicate directly with the people you
like with no big tech nonsense so that's
that's why we did that and as I
mentioned to you guys a couple weeks ago
we did all of our fundraising in the
midst of corona like as all hell was
breaking loose like two days before just
as they were talking about lock downs I
was in San Francisco in San Francisco is
sort of the hub of like paranoia and
weirdness and whatever and we're in
there
trying to get out cuz I didn't want to
be trapped in freakin San Francisco
during the lockdown but we were able to
fundraise quite well we're adding Live
Chat by the way which we should have in
the app I think by next week we're beta
testing it right now we have some
livestream video coming and all sorts of
stuff and there's no BOTS and trolls cuz
it's it's a gated community so anyway so
I'm super curious generally how you guys
are behaving with with social media
specifically like it's not just the
stuff that you're watching maybe or you
watch a lot of YouTube videos although
you can get trapped in in that hole too
right like every now and again I'll just
Google like you know Star Wars fan
fiction thing and like before I know it
it's like two hours later and I've
watched like 30 horrible things and
there's one good one but you just keep
clicking and clicking click and not to
mention someone will send me a tick tock
video every now and again and I'm not
even I think maybe I have a tick tock
account but I'm not using it and it's
like when you start on one tick tock
thing man it's next thing you know it's
three years later ya know it's like I
should I brush my teeth
alright guys I want to get to a couple
of your questions because you gave me
many of them here you go
Stacy says have you watched hoaxed so I
haven't seen hoaxes yet that's Mike
Serna bitch's documentary about media
manipulation which I from what I
understand is doing incredibly well
online right now I think unless I did
something else with him years ago right
when when my career was sort of taking
off he did interview me for a
documentary and I think it was hoax so
maybe I'm in hoax I'm not even sure but
I haven't seen yet but I would be
interested in to in seeing it of all
superheroes Marvel or DC who would you
say is your favorite either from the
movies or the comics themselves this is
from Devin you know I think my all-time
favorite so I was a big comic book kid
you know in a bigger way than I am now
you know the movies have all become sort
of stiff and I you know I've said this a
couple times but at the end of endgame
it just felt to me like that was the
ultimate orgy of all of those movies and
when I left even though I really liked
it and I actually liked it even more the
second time I saw it on a plane it seems
to me that we desperately need new
stories and new characters and and like
a new creative ethos to like talk about
our present
now it doesn't mean those things all
have to go away but we really need to
reinvent them like it just felt like
enough they've just given us absolutely
everything but as a kid growing up with
comic books and I have a whole bunch
maybe I'll take some pictures of what
we've got in the in the green room over
there I've got I've got some great comic
books I grew up reading spider-man and
Batman and GI Joe and transformers and
x-men and and a bunch of other stuff I
never really like Superman actually he
was just too perfect it was like the
Kryptonite thing it was like this is
boring which by the way is why I think
the movies generally are not good it's
like the guy can't be hurt by anything
but this one thing so yeah at some point
in the movie they're gonna get the one
thing and then he's gonna be okay and
yada yada
Spider Man though is is my favorite not
necessarily the Spider Man now I'll do
although I do think that kid is good
it's like a little too cutesy for me but
when I was reading comic books I was in
the Spider Man like in the 200s phase I
don't know what spider-man's on right
now I'd love to know but the amazing
spider-man comic book and there was an
incredible run so when I was probably
like maybe 13 13 to 15 something like
that was the years that Spiderman was in
like the two 90s into the three 40s and
it was this guy Todd McFarlane who's an
absolutely incredible artist and I have
like most of them couple of them up
there spider-man 300 he was just an
incredible artist and then they had some
great writing at the time and Spiderman
felt a little more mature I don't think
back then I really thought of him as
like a high school kid where it's very
much based in like the high school nosov
it now but there was always like a humor
to him he was like a real person too you
know we're you know Bruce Wayne let's
say is like a little stiffer and he's a
rich guy where spider-man he grew up in
Queens like I was born in Brooklyn like
there's something about the spider-man
lore and the artwork and all that good
stuff Tommy says what kind of coffee are
you drinking these days so you know as
as lockdown went let me get a sip we're
running to the supermarkets like
everybody else and I was like if there's
one thing I cannot run out of if all
hell breaks loose if there's one thing
that I need during this to be functional
in any way its coffee so I've got like
10 bags of beans in there and I just
kind of grabbed a whole bunch of
different stuff one of the ones that I
generally like is I like peeps
Coffee I get the beans I grind on myself
the the major Dickinson blend I find
it's kind of dark I like a darker coffee
I put the tiniest bit of right now I'm
doing like an oat creamer in there I
think it's a hazelnut creamer I put like
the tiny drop of that in there but I
also have some bulletproof coffee and
then some just some random brands I
think I've got just like a Whole Foods
tin but I do like grinding the beans
like there's something about that
process and then doing it in the French
press letting it sit there for a little
bit check an email or to get Clyde out
to pee and then like start the day but I
am I am a big coffee guy for sure
torrid lover says this Clyde get table
scraps what kind of dog food do you feed
him dry or wet or both love the pupper
so he so far so we've had him for a
little over a month right now which
really was like the best thing we could
have done during rock down and I'm you
know when I posted pictures of him and
talked about adopting him and everything
so many of you guys have talked about
adopting dogs and your fostering dogs
and I know many of the shelter's right
now actually don't need anyone some of
them do they were because they were
overflowing at first but so many people
have taken dogs which is obviously
awesome we feed him wellness it's a dry
wellness food it's oatmeal and something
oatmeal and chicken something something
it's a purple bag and then I do a tiny
bit of wet food in there he has not had
any table scraps so far we have done it
right it's been hard to do because
obviously we're eating home three meals
a day but he has not even had like the
tiniest piece of steak or chicken yet
he's like half trained he's house
trained but you know he's still he's one
he's very jumpy he's on us all the time
trying to get on the couch trying to
jump in bed so we're working on all that
stuff and you know at some point will we
break and we'll eat some human food of
course and as you guys know when when
Emma got sick for that last year we
cooked for her for the year so I don't
love the idea of having to give him dog
food all the time but like right now
it's not like we can be cooking for the
dog all right guys I'm gonna do one more
they want me to keep these to about 20
minutes there's a method behind the
madness but if you want to communicate
with me throughout the day I do plenty
of talking to you guys responding to
questions and thoughts and emails and
posting private videos and all a bunch
of whole bunch of other stuff at Rueben
report.com and I will add one more
question in here
let's go political we didn't do too much
political stuff this is max justice he
says should Trump Institute a national
voter ID I I don't have a problem with
the national voter ID you know this is
one of the weird things I talked about
this actually yesterday with with Dan
Crenshaw the left is completely against
voter IDs which makes no sense to me you
need a you need a ID to drive a car you
need an ID to get on a plane you need an
ID to buy a beer right now we could have
a libertarian debate us whether any of
that's legit but if as a society we're
saying there are basic things simple
things that you need to do to have you
know you have to have an ID for well the
voting absolutely should be one of them
the fact that I was able to vote when it
when this passed for the primaries the
Democratic primaries that I just walked
into a place said my name and then they
just let me in there was no esque
they didn't ask me for an ID or anything
uh-huh that that actually seems pretty
crazy and I think the reason the left
doesn't want it I mean it's fairly
obvious they want to make sure that
people that are not legal citizens of
the United States can vote or that
people can vote twice or the rest of it
now this idea that somehow poor people
or certain a certain race of people
can't get IDs is insane everyone has
ideas there's all these videos out there
people on the right do these videos all
the time with oh go to poor
neighborhoods and they'll just ask
people do you have an ID and everyone
says yes now if the idea here is that
somebody somehow can't get an ID I am
all for this would be a good use of
federal funds right let's make sure
everyone has an ID so that everyone can
vote and that would actually make sure
there would be less tampering with votes
this is another thing right now Ilhan
Omer is pushing for mail-in votes and
it's like that's just more chances for
manipulation so if you're against voter
ID you might be the one that's a little
misguided here and it's and someone
that's for it isn't for it because they
don't want poor people to vote or they
don't want black people to vote or some
some idiotic accusation that we know is
the same accusation that's always thrown
at everyone that doesn't agree with the
the progressive groupthink of the day
okay guys I have a long day of
interviews I'm not doing any more
interviews today I'm doing press for
don't burn this book so again it's don't
burn this book calm join me on Ruben
report calm we've got an iOS app
search Reuben report in the Apple store
or in the Google Play Store and have a
great day everybody stay saying get out
there take a walk every now and again
snitch on a neighbor be a good American
whatever it is or buy seeds you know
here in LA one more thing here in LA we
can still buy seeds in Michigan they
can't buy seeds I was at the hardware
store yesterday I was about to clean
them out and just ship them to Michigan
to people in Michigan if you're in
Michigan and you want seeds I want to
send you seeds
send me a message on Reuben report.com I
will send you seeds it's on me alright
guys thanks have a great day everybody